Before I was an Avenger, I made mistakes.
And a lot of enemies.
His callsign is Taskmaster. He controls the Red Room.
I should have come back for you. How many others are there?
Enough
We have to go back to where it all started.
So they never do that to anyone again.
We're a family. We fight with you!
You won't win.
I've always found it best,
not to look into the past.
Okay, you gotta plan? Or shall I just stay duck and cover? My plan was to drive us away.
Well, your plan sucks.
At some point we all have to choose.
Between what the world wants you to be.
And who you are.
I made my choice.
I'm done running.
Here's whats gonna happen. Natasha, don't slouch. I'm not slouching!
You're going to get a back hunch. Hmm, listen to your mother. Up! Up!
Alright, enough. All of you. I didn't say anything. That's not fair.
Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to be my new black widow video
they just announced some early screening details.
This is crazy planned the Disney and Marvel
have in his all to do with sports believe
it or not also talk about what's going on
with taskmaster falcon winter soldier that
thunderbolts thunderbolt Ross.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
will do a new Amazon giveaway all you do to
enter is be subscriber and leave all your
predictions for the black widow movie on the
video so first things first.
If you didn't see the news yesterday.
There was this giant announcement the Disney
in the NBA made because the NBA's getting
ready to restart their season like a lot of
other major sports they had to stop there
season because the virus so because the NBA
is losing hundreds of millions of dollars
they want to find a place where they can safely
play the rest of their season in a self-contained
sort of environment so Disney naturally says
we have Disney World please bring all the
NBA teams that are going to participate down
here will put you up we have this giant sports
facility we have all these hotels we have
this giant resort that all your families can
live at so Disney is finalizing negotiations
with the NBA to bring as many the league teams
are going to be part of this season two Disney
World the basically going tobe playing there
season from July 31 to October 31.
That's when the NBA files are supposed and
later this year, but everyone was reporting
yesterday that is part of Disney trying to
sweeten the deal because they would make a
lot of money if he NBA hosted events at Disney
World they want them to come to Disney World
they're offering to screen it Disney movies
way before they ever hit theaters for the
NBA their families, everyone is going to be
staying at Disney World during this period
between July 31 and October 31, for instance
this reporter saying this is accurate per
Walt Disney sources Disney will make movies
available for players and their families.
Once they join once they bring the league
down to Disney World.
This is likely to include movies that have
not been seen or released to the general public,
including marbles black widow which is currently
being released in theaters in November.
So number four now.
Everyone's googling how to become an NBA player
because it does sound like Disney is going
to lock down the NBA they will wind up doing
this crazy plan to play out the rest of the
NBA games all at Disney World is not like
you have to be drafted into the NBA and become
a player just to watch black widow early you
could be one of their family members you could
be someone who works for an NBA team.
So you know anybody in the NBA and you live
somewhere near Florida and Disney World.
There's a pretty solid chance you can actually
see black widow early everybody suddenly call
in every single favor that they have with
anybody.
This associated with the NBA even though they
just mention the black widow movie screening
early.
It would be pretty much every movie the Disney
has this getting ready to screen around this
time.
The NBA will be there so they could wind up
screening Marvel's internals little bit early
for them to because that's going tobe marbles
February movie next year just because everything
got moved down the bench because black widow
got bumped, but number three getting back
to actual marble stuff.
The black widow movie Marvel phase for the
taskmaster character within the plot of black
widow which is taking place after Captain
America Civil War.
But before Avengers infinity war taskmaster
is sort of rebooted the red room is now running
it himself.
Remember that scene in Avengers when Loki
is taunting black widow and he starts reading
her all those terrible things that she's done
all the red on her ledger and he calls her
Drake off's daughter Drake off is actually
the Russian general in these flashbacks that
Melina is talking to in the red room here.
So he was the one that was in charge of the
red room, but within the context of the MCU.
He was the person that took Natosha in after
her biological family died in gave her to
the red room.
So even though most of the movie is taking
place right after Captain America Civil War
some of the movie will address her distant
past her origins her childhood thanks to scarlet
which is powers, we get a little bit of that
during Avengers age of Ultron, but that just
touches on a little bit of the different types
of training.
She went through and her quote of quote final
exam the whole reason why she's in Russia
during the black widow movie is because she
finds out that they restarted the red room
program and they're going to take it way bigger
than they ever did before is going tocome back
with a vengeance because of what taskmaster
is doing.
So unless they are pulling a really really
cool fast one on us taskmaster for the most
part is the main villain in the black widow
movie in the whole idea that he sort of throws
the Avengers in her face because he can copy
all the Avengers moves like even though technically
Black Panther is an actual avenger yet you
see them copying Black Panthers moves with
what it looks like replicas of his vibramium
claws we learn of this is actual vibranium
that he has on his claws here, but its imply
that it is because of all the black market
by premium trade that we've seen in the MCU
so far that you very much Ulysses Klaw remember
he said he had a buyer for some of the vibrating
that they stole of the museum it could have
been taskmaster that bought that by premium
he's even got some straight up Spider-Man
moves so that lets you know how close to Captain
America Civil War.
This is taking place because he's basically
watching a lot of the Avengers highlight reels
just to learn all there moves never to the
reason why this is so big for marble phase
for even though the movie set in the past
is because of the taskmaster character and
thunderbolt Ross why would you put thunderbolt
Ross in the movie if it did not something
to do with what's going on in present day
and he did not get into any fights during
Captain America Civil War himself.
This is what he looked like his hair had streaks
of blackened and what is he look so different
in the shots here.
It's totally possible that this has something
to do with what's going on during falcon winter
soldier in this will lead into the rebooting
of the super soldier program.
The whole idea being that he sort of a parallel
for the taskmaster character, because taskmaster
is doing all these shady things with the red
room program and the new black widow's in
Russia, because the synopsis of the falcon
winter soldier series is that someone restarts
quote of quote the weapons plus program that
we saw thunderbolt Ross messing with during
Incredible Hulk.
He's putting together a version of a team
that he can control, because nothing the Avengers
are kind of on hiatus temporarily even though
there are Avengers that are still alive still
out there only Ironman and Captain America
have been benched, so to speak is going tobe
a while before the Avengers reassemble again
for Avengers five, so obviously there's threats
that need to be dealt with thunderbolt Ross
is on the world Security Council.
He's basically the president's number one
man for stuff like that.
So he needs something to take care of that
threat.
That's where the thunderbolts come in a team
that he can control and he can jack up with
the weapons plus program.
Even though most of the weapons plus program
stuff that we see in the MCU has to do with
the super soldier program.
It's not all about that in the comics, each
different iteration of the weapons plus program
gets some different type of treatment to try
and enhance them really good example that
is when the got two weapon 10 weapon X Wolverine
in the comics.
They didn't give him the super soldier serum
he already had mutant powers they just grafted
the adamantine to his skeleton to make him
relatively indestructible.
So number one the whole idea here being
that even though taskmaster is the main villain
of the black widow movie.
This will carry forward into marble phase
for because the whole ideas that were in marble
phase for pushing the story forward of the
Avengers, but because present-day is in 2023
yet to have some sort of time jump sort of
address what happens after the events of the
black widow movie sorely post credit scene
or ending of the movie theory this actor we
know is playing the taskmaster character.
That's what he looks like underneath the mask
thunderbolt Ross will find him and recruit
him for a future thunderbolts team and even
though Marvel hasn't formally announced a
thunderbolts Disney plus series or thunderbolts
movie will probably wait for a couple years
before doing something like that slowly build
the team out the same way that they did for
the first Avengers movie.
It took them about four years to get to that
first Avengers movie, so everyone just post
all your theories in the comments below.
How will the black widow movie affect what's
going forward in marble phase 4, especially
with the Disney plus series.
It because falcon winter soldier is literally
going to start dropping in the fall before the
black widow movie starts while you wait for
everything.
Click here for my brand-new Spider-Man into
the spider verse two teaser video and.
That new miles morales Spider-Man PS5 trailer
and click here for my brand-new wonder woman
1984 trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe, I'll see you guys tonight!